[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Maryland wilshire host and our guest is
bo hopkins a professor at yale school of
management and the macmillan centre is
more than 30 years of private industry
investment management and consulting
experience and he's been a managing
partner with CM equity partner since
1999 his coursework at Yale has been
designed to introduce graduate and
undergraduate students to practical
issues faced by mission-driven social
entrepreneurs based in Africa India and
other developing nations today we'll
talk with professor Hopkins about the
unique course he's currently teaching
that uses market based practices as a
means to bring sustainable social
benefits to locally impoverished to
regions of Africa welcome professor
Hopkins thank you must be here so let's
begin with the course that you're
teaching tell us about it ok so the this
is for undergraduates ok usually
sophomores rising two juniors or juniors
rising two seniors and the reason I say
that is because it's a year long class
and the class covers a calendar year not
an academic year ok so students in my
class are sophomores right now by the
time they finish in December they will
obviously be juniors the reason it's set
up that way is because we're going to do
in the first term sort of my pedagogical
approach to what is social enterprise
and the characteristics that make
enterprises successful when they're
principally driven by some social
mission as opposed to a pure profit
motivation but what I really want the
students to have an opportunity to do is
work in the field with practitioners who
are doing this and so part of the summer
months are set aside for the students to
travel to in this case in this term
Africa and in three or four different
countries we're still putting the
project together to explore the
challenges on the ground not just
explore them sort of in the classroom in
New Haven so what we do is we have the
you'll approach then we have the summer
experience for the students they work in
teams of three and then we have them
come back to New Haven and we not only
deconstruct what their experiences were
on the ground and how it differed from
the classroom education part but then we
look at three different things what is
the project they worked on for the host
client and how do we advance their host
clients mission by the work that the
students do so that's like a research
project right I want the students to
write a case study about the experience
so that they can articulate why this is
what their experience was and how it
relates to the field of social
enterprise in this example and then in a
case study there's usually a teaching
note and so I work with the students on
developing a teaching notes that we can
actually use these cases in the future
whether at Yale or somewhere else okay
and social enterprise what exactly does
that term mean in terms of the class
you're teaching well a mission-driven
enterprise is probably the easiest way
to say I think of also all businesses
are social one way or the other a
mission-driven Enterprise prioritizes
bringing a certain good or service or
value to a population that doesn't
benefit the way we do from classic
market making opportunities so if we
think about some of the basic statistics
there are seven billion people in the
world four billion of them left live on
less than two dollars a day three
dollars a day depending how you count
purchasing power parity and those
individuals have needs but they also
have demands and so how do needs and
demands begin to interrelate and as we
think about building an organizational
practice an enterprise or a business we
sort of have to stop looking at needs a
little bit and start thinking about
demand and how do we then think about
bringing services or goods to satisfy a
demand or in some cases even help create
that demand so it's different from a
philanthropic mission and it's different
from a fewer pure for-profit mission and
we're looking at examples today of how
how these markets are created why
undergraduates and not for instance the
graduate level there's some great work
going on at the graduate school som has
a great program on global social
enterprise we can see program
around other universities mostly at the
graduate level what I think is great
about the undergraduates is a they have
the time first of all I'm in a four year
program with them and not a two year
program so giving up a summer is a
possibility a practical standpoint of
view but they're they're energetic
they're inquisitive they're not trying
to find the answer they're trying to
find the questions right what is it that
makes this work not how does it work in
Business School the challenge is always
how do you how do you how do you get to
the answer all right we're trying to
figure out what are the questions how do
we how do we get the students to
formulate their ideas and their own
hypothesis about this so you know
standard rule in my book is younger is
better okay and how did you come to
teach the course what you know what drew
you to Yale I know your background is
financial primarily so is there some
overlap there well I mean so my
connection to Yale is through som I was
a graduate class of 86 and I've lived
nearby New York nearby and I've remained
involved with you so I did a lot of
volunteer work I've aya som Alumni
Association the Yale Annual Fund I've
worked with all these organizations and
just gotten to know more people in the
community and as that's happened I've
I've had an opportunity to interact with
professors and talk about different
ideas and it was then the former dean of
som who said you know I'd really like
you to help me brainstorm on a couple of
class ideas and we did that and then he
gave the assignment to teach it to
somebody else which was a good idea but
it opened my eyes to say wow other there
might be a way to do some work with Yale
where I can actually get involved in the
classroom and have even more opportunity
to design my own questions and think
about this space and then I got lucky
you know I met Jim Levinson and we were
talking about this and he said I'd
really like to have an experimental
class with you and see if it works that
was seven years ago and here we are
today so the class is primarily based
looking at Africa correct so in this
iteration this iteration I'm pointed to
the African Studies department of
macmillan and so we contextualize it
around the continent of Africa which is
a pretty big place when you think about
when I've done the class in the past
we've
use the global canvas so we look at
we've allowed students to sort of go
where they want so we've had we've had
students look studying microfinance in
Kazakhstan we've had students looking at
off-grid energy systems in northern
India we've had students look at mobile
payment processing in Nicaragua so all
of those opportunities were sort of
created by the students now that we're
contextualizing around Africa I'm doing
a little bit more work to help find the
projects that fit though okay and let's
talk a little bit about that so what are
you doing projects or how do i find it
how you find them finding a museum is a
is a is a classic networking opportunity
or operation right so I start here at
Yale and we look at where our alumni and
where are the relationships and then we
start talking about who can i meet on
the phone who can i start talking about
this idea of the classroom experience
fortunately i got enough years of
experience in it where i can illustrate
what I think the opportunities are for
both the students and the host and then
I'll usually spend a few weeks in Africa
over the summer myself prospecting
looking for organizations as much as I
can tie it back to Yale I think that's a
great thing sure sure so let's talk
about specifics let's talk about the
class you're teaching now have the
students identified what they're going
to be doing this summer at this point
yes or so so the advantage of me sort of
doing some of the pre-screen work is we
get earlier into the host relationship
and so we're working with five
organizations and each of them are in
contact with the students at this point
in time what's going on in addition to
the pedagogy is the students are
beginning to make the relationships over
skype and over the phone with their
hosts starting to bring in some of the
data that is available to them to start
to understand how the business
operations work and we've done some work
scoping the projects what specifically
will the students do when they're in the
field in in Kenya Rwanda say okay and
what countries are are being explored I
mean what well so it depends I mean
we've had in this particular iteration
it looks like we're going to be a little
heavy in
and Kenya I've had students in South
Africa and six other countries in in
Africa over the life cycle of the course
but this time it looks like it'll be
Kenyan Rwanda for the most part okay
looking back at some of the courses
you've taught previously in that you
know in the same manner can you cite any
specific examples that were particularly
successful for the students and why was
it so successful so we have to be a
little careful on what the definition of
success is so for the most part I'm
really just trying to get a student
experience here there's not really a
product or a or a final element at the
end right I want the students to be
really open-minded to have a chance to
explore and in this interesting new
space and to contribute but at the end
of the class assignment you know that's
really as far as we're really taking it
having said that there are always some
really fun success stories and so I've
had a chance to teach at the global
affairs department Africa studies now
School of Management and the School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences so I'll
give you one example from from applied
sciences okay and I'll give you one
example from global affairs in the
applied sciences class I worked in the
center for engineering innovation design
with Professor Jones inter and among
that and we did we did a class called
appropriate technology for the
developing world and one of the things
that we used as a prop one year was the
cold day the cold chain the vaccine cold
chain and that's a system that the
students had to learn about as to how
drugs are manufactured in one place need
to be kept within a certain temperature
banned throughout their entire supply
chain distribution or they lose their
efficacy and how do you get a drug or a
series of drugs all the way through that
chain to the last mile in a regional
area of Africa or India you pick the
place right we ask the students to come
up with several different hypotheses
around how once they studied the cold
chain and did interviews around who the
actors and the end the principal
mechanisms for delivery were to
brainstorm on different ideas what they
would do if they were engaged in this
space and one student team really wanted
to learn about the demand
side of the equation at the final last
mile so they postulated a was a time of
bracelet it became a necklace which is
ultimately become a organization called
Khushi baby where they can read and
write the vaccine record to on any
individual baby's health card
electronically so we use a mobile phone
to go out into the field and bring back
and write data here's when the baby was
vaccinated or here why the baby here's
why the baby wasn't vaccinated and then
we can bring that information back and
upload it into the cloud now we have a
full working database as opposed to an
analog record of notebooks students took
that out of the classroom one a couple
of prizes got a little capital to go to
India trial it with a host partner and
today three and a half years later
they're working with over 900 villages
mostly in udaipur around Jaipur and did
I poor and said they were in Rajasthan
who died poor being the headquarters and
are constantly innovating the model that
they have great success from a
standpoint of view of a classroom idea
getting into the field in the Jackson
global affairs department oftentimes
we'll have the students write cases and
submit them to a case competition one of
the cases 2015 came in first place in
the international case competition it
was 70 different cases applied mostly
written by professors some graduate
students and our undergraduates came in
first and third out of the three places
really comin oh that's great and quite a
testament to you I'm sure as a teacher
as well now when you're in the classroom
and the students are formulating their
projects I'm curious too there's also
there's always with the theoretical of
you know formula formulating you know
something in the classroom and then
hitting the reality when you're in the
field let's talk about some of the
situations that have come up
in that area well so there's there's
there's sort of different kinds of
challenges right the first challenge is
can we actually build a project which
has the right scale and scope that
students can contribute to its
frustrating to the students and
organizations if there's a mismatch
there because the students can end up
being subtractive from the whole
enterprise right there they take time
they take energy they got to be managed
to some extent if they're not on the
ground contributing then it's a
subtraction right we try to avoid that
by doing a lot of the scoping work up
front building the client relationship
very early on after that it's the
student travel experience right now
we've had students who have been we had
students who are flying to Kenya on the
exact day to meet their client on the
exact day that there was the bombing in
Nairobi's mall well that shut everything
down I had students stranded in Dubai I
had students who hadn't left yet I had
another student in London and they were
all trying to figure out how they were
going to get together and make it work
and they did pull it together and make
it work but it was not the ideal
scenario so there are practical
challenges to to the same kind of things
we do and there are structural
challenges to the kinds of things that
we do and it takes a lot of time that
with me to try to help make sure that
all those things go as smoothly as
possible how had any surprises even
teaching now for a few years is there
anything that potentially could surprise
you at this point I don't even want to
think about that wow you know I didn't
think about that you know during the
course of you teaching for the past
years so look there have been 60 kids
have gone out in the field and 60 kids
welcome back great they've all had a
great experience and the organizations
are generally pretty happy with how
they're not how it works I think that
the surprises are because I see the kids
for a year I should say students they're
going to laugh at me now when I hear me
say that I want to see the students for
a year I really get to develop a little
bit of a relationship with them so I can
see how they're also evolving in their
thinking as the term terms go by but
[ __ ] the biggest surprises and the best
things are all is when I get a
now from a student who is actually in
the space working in the field we had
one actually two students work with in
Ghana with an organization called micro
ensure that was their summer project and
they took full time positions with that
organization at the end of the year and
so or the end when they graduate so one
worked in in Ghana the other worked in
Kenya for a year the one who spent time
in Ghana is now working with an
organization called the African
Leadership universities in Mauritius and
it's a very ambitious program where
they're building 25 different
universities around Africa educate the
next level of leadership for Africa you
know the the for Africans by Africans
and it's terrific and I know the oh I
know the founder of that organization
but that was just coincidental to the
fact that this student ended up there so
a surprise for me is when I hear about
that and his name is Michael and Michael
came back this first day of class this
term and so then he was there in front
of the class addressing the students
exactly where he had been three or four
years ago yeah terrific that is a
wonderful opportunity I think for the
students so ultimately what would you
like your students to take away from
your class social enterprises we said
earlier is is a mission-driven focus
it's looking at where problems are in
the world and trying to think of the
tools that could be used which go beyond
just pure philanthropy which is great or
or or donated time to thinking about the
organizational construction of how to
fundamentally address these pervasive
problems and it doesn't have to be in in
the developing world it can happen right
here it can happen right in New Haven
there are big disparities and income as
we understand right so how do you take
what is a relatively lower income part
of a population and redesign a good or
service that helps that individual in or
those communities build themselves up
right my approach to thinking about it
is to use the market mechanisms and
that's the structure that we use inside
the classroom and so that goes to
how do we think about business creation
how do we gear our activities how do we
keep costs low how do we build a
relationship with the customer those
types of activities are important
because we have such a thin margin to
work with oftentimes you see these
organizations have two arms one is
philanthropic and one is business
because the philanthropic part the
building of the network or the building
of the infrastructure to support the
business isn't really market-based but
parts of it can be and so that leads to
long-term sustainability in the end at
Maryland you know look I went to som
right we think about you know business
for leaders first for business and
society right how do we sink that
through at a young age level right how
do we just ask the questions and get
them thinking about it because whether
they go to Goldman Sachs or they go to
McKinsey or they go to UNICEF or
wherever they end up going they're going
to be engaged in this throughout their
lives and if we have that dialogue now I
and they have an experience that they
can remember now I think it's
transformative and so that's my theory
of change for how it influenced the
students excellent thank you so much for
being here with us today thank you for
having us but a lot of fun okay great
for more information about professor
Hopkins and his work please visit our
website at macmillan report yale edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
[Music]